i'm loving severance you know i was
saying on the air yesterday i i started
watching it because you were coming on
and at first i go how am i going to stay
with this thing because you're showing
the tedium of office work
it's a challenge to tell a story about
people who have no attachment to their
work so you didn't write this nope this
was a script written by a writer named
dan erickson who who submitted it to our
production company five plus years ago
and as a writing sample and i read it
and uh jackie cohen works at our company
and uh my producing partner read it and
this we thought oh this is great it's a
great writing table and i was like this
is let's can we make this and and that
was that's how we started with it how
many scripts like even you just telling
this story now it was a writing sample
somebody sent in yeah
how many of these scripts do you get
on a daily basis
where i'm and most i would say probably
i'm asking is it like 90 99 of them are
junk honestly i don't read all those you
know right and that's you know you they
they get submitted they'll come through
you know through
agency or they'll come into our company
and somebody will read them and
uh maybe an intern will read or maybe
the creative executive and then if
there's something that seems really good
or interesting then send it over to me
so it's very rare when you get a writing
sample like you did with severance and
you go oh my god this guy's on to
something this is an intriguing idea yes
yeah and because i have by the way i
have passed on things that
then i regretted for sure you know like
what what did you pass on and you said
oh [ __ ] and then you see it and you go
oh my god good will hunting oh directing
good
are you serious
so when that when something like that
happens which good will hunting one of
the best movies ever made right
i haven't watched it for a while
but
um
in other words the boys handed you the
script they were younger i don't i don't
know if they even knew that i got it um
but i got i got sent by my agent at the
time and
the first turn off was that these two
guys were attached to it to act in it
who wrote it i was like what come on ooh
well you're right like who are they cast
my own projects
[Laughter]
i'm ben stiller who are these guys all
right i attached myself to the things
i've written and then i
don't want anybody else to attach them
so that was that was the one that i uh
was like uh all right
missed the book and that night when the
academy awards were on and those two
guys are up there cheering you guys
screaming
you're like oh my god well how the hell
do you question your whole existence but
you can never really know right no you
never know and you just have to and
sometimes it's just like where you're at
in your life at that moment and you go
okay that was good but i just i really
couldn't do it at that time you know
just wasn't right for me at that moment